[Music]
congratulations are in order you've just
had this stunning series of successes so
really and you seem like this is
well-earned this is great yeah not just
going crazy everyone's got Hammerstein
[Applause]
[Music]
that's good I am a busy couple years you
know and and and our full thing you know
I kind of kicked it off and and then the
snow one the Huntsman and you know both
films people loved and you know that's
that's the the biggest reward is that
pat on the back
you know it's been all going so great
you had one disappointment which is MTV
Movie Awards just gave out the award for
best hero you were up for that I thought
you were shoo-in tell us who won Harry
Potter Harry Potter yeah I just kept
thinking like thoughts got this big
magical hammer forged from the heart of
a dying star summons the lightning
thunder foot you know split the earth
enough and pot has got a wooden stick
yes basil put us in a cage we should
sort that out properly but you think
yeah Thor versus Harry Potter that I
wanted wouldn't you like to see that
[Applause]
give me a hard time I think he's good
and he should I think might be human The
Avengers
could be you know a valid addition you
think he would fit in with the Avengers
everything else just seems so dynamic
and he's always worried like mm I mean
having a little something he's always
worried about cutting classes and so
it's not the same intensity it's not
quite not do like I would think there
are some challenges to playing for like
I'm told that costume is technically
it's yeah it's big its machinery heavy
and we had or I had this this vest
basically which had this tubing and that
run through it and then we're under the
costume and you'd plug into a machine
that would send cold water up into it
because it gets very hot it's very hot
okay but the problem is the tube I would
hang have hanging out my costume
occasionally I forget to tuck it in to
be dripping fluid to clog add a catheter
with a bladder problem no no I like um
it's leaking again yeah yeah it's a sad
Thor sir it's the Thor who didn't take
care of himself